l'opportunité qui m'a été qui m'a été
proposée de pouvoir
tourner un court-métrage
sur la sécurité routière était pour moi
effectivement un moyen de mettre des
images
sur
sur ce qui est devenu aujourd'hui ma vie
peu de temps après mon accident j'ai
eu l'initiative avec mon épouse de
de créer une association qui s'appelle
grand bleu que l'on trouve aujourd'hui
sur Facebook
le l'objectif premier c'est de récolter
des fonds pour pouvoir
accéder plus facilement à des
équipements adaptés de pouvoir
rassembler des gens autour de cette
nouvelle vie de pouvoir les les informer
sur les dangers de la route
j'ai eu mon accident le 28 juillet 2013
c'était un dimanche après-midi et je
n'ai pas mis ma ceinture dans un virage
en épingle je j'ai perdu le contrôle de
mon véhicule j'ai été éjecté mon
véhicule c'est retombé sur moi j'ai eu
donc une atteinte au cervicale qui va
qui a engendré une tétraplégie
ou plus dur des moments à passer c'est à
dire accepter le fait que du jour au
lendemain on se retrouve paralysé mes
enfants
restent le moteur principal de
de cette nouvelle vie de cette
reconstruction je sais que sans eux
j'aurais eu beaucoup plus de mal mon
épouse est aussi
si ce n'est le moteur principal de
cette nouvelle famille elle me soutient
elle m'encourage elle me
elle me réconforte